Okay.
In this video,
we'll look at a little bit
more the details of why
it's difficult to train deep
neural network.
Okay.
So I mentioned in the previous video
that historically we've often found that
training a single hidden their neural
network without say a second hidden,
they're like in this case,
uh,
would often work better than
having a two or more hidden layers.
And,
uh,
even though there are some problems where
we'd actually think that we would gain
by having many hidden layers. So, uh,
well I'll talk about in this video is
two types of reasons where we tend to see
this difficulty, which will help
us then introduce ways of, of, uh,
addressing these difficulties and, uh, uh,
solve our problems and get
effective learning algorithms
or deep neural networks.
Yeah,
yeah. Actually, two types of problems
was, are, uh, or difficulty difficulties,
which are quite different.
Uh,
so the first is that a training,
a deep neural network is a
harder optimization problem
than training a single
hidden, they're known network, um,
in particular. So in this case,
we would be in an under fitting a
situation where if we had a better
optimization procedure, then,
uh, we should be able to, uh, if,
if indeed we are having a harder
time to optimize on neural network,
then it means we're probably
could fit the data better.
So it would be then in under fitting a
situation, which would mean that, uh,
we would get better results
in digitalization by, uh,
optimizing better fitting better
our training data. So this,
uh, difficulty optimization is
often a, it is trading by, uh,
the vanishing gradient problem,
which is a well known problem
in a neural networks, uh,
essentially corresponds to the
following, uh, following situation.
So, uh, we, uh, if we go back to
the backpropagation algorithm,
we know that whenever we are taking the
gradient of the activation of a unit and
then we passing that gradient to get
degree in, in of the pre activation,
we have to multiply by the
partial derivative of the
activation with respect to
their pre activation.
Now if the hidden unit is at,
it's a core close to a saturation
point, that is, it's uh, it has a,
it's a activation close to the
highest or lowest value it can take.
It means that the partial dude IV
is going to be very close to zero,
which means that the gradient with respect
to the pre activation is going to be
close to zero because we're
multiplying by that partial derivative.
And so it means that at this point,
not all the great is being back
propagated towards the other layers.
Below is going to be very close to zero.
And if we repeat this process many times,
and we have many saturated hidden
units in means, uh, as we get closer,
closer to the input layer, we get great
ins that are closer and closer to zero.
So that's why we say that
the gradient is Spanish ing.
And this is essentially caused by the,
uh,
saturated units because saturated in units
as essentially a partial do they have
a of zero. And so that essentially
shrinks the gradient, uh,
towards zero.
And so that's a big problem because
intuitively the advantage of having hidden
units that are non linear and saturate
is that it makes the prediction non
linear and we want that nonlinearity.
So we actually want the neural network
to get to a regime which is close to the
saturation point to take advantage of,
uh,
the nonlinear already of the hidden units.
But as we get there,
we get great ins that become a closer
and closer to zero and yet towards the
vanishing gradient situation.
Um,
and so there's sort of this dilemma here,
which is very unfortunate,
which is that when we get to a situation
where we're signing to be in the
interesting configuration of the
neural network, which is non linear,
while it becomes actually
harder and harder to optimize
because the green it is,
becomes very small for the first
hidden layers, which might not train,
uh, at all. Uh,
with respect to how quickly the
top hit in layers with train.
And which means that these
hidden units here are,
these units here might start to adapt to
hidden units that are more or less, uh,
a random because they're,
they're not actually training as quickly
as the connections that are here.
For instance, this is in fact a well
known problem in record neural networks.
The fact that there's
this dilemma between, uh,
getting gradient that pass as well
through the hidden layers and being in a
situation where the neural network
is in a configuration that allows for
saturation and there's more interesting,
uh,
I'm not going to talk about this too much,
but there's quite a bit of
a few papers about that.
So that's the first hypothesis
that optimize optimization
is harder and this is
made harder in particular by
the fact that hidden units,
saturate and block gradients when we
back propagate them towards the, uh,
all the lower hidden layers
is second possibility is that we are
actually not in or fitting situation.
But in overfitting situation that is
when we're considering the possibility of
having many hidden layers.
It means that we're exploring a
more complex space of functions.
So functions are more and more
complicated and there are many,
many more of them that are functions as
we add layers and a possible functions
we can, we can model.
And also just one way of,
of sort of informally measuring the
complexity of a space of functions is to
consider the number of parameters
if these functions are parametrized.
So in the deep neural net,
the parameters are all the connections.
And of course when we add more layers we
have more parameters. So, um, you know,
we can expect that we'd get
some overfitting problems
where we'd be in this, uh,
hi Varun,
slow bias situation.
Where are the family of deep networks
corresponds to a very large space of
possible functions and
forgiven training set. Uh,
there'd be many function that would reach,
say zero error or close
to zero error and uh, and,
and also if we varied the training set
because our space of functions is very,
very complex,
it can adapt very easily.
Then we actually get very many different,
uh,
neural networks as we say,
varied the training center.
So this would correspond
to a high variance.
We have low bias because neural nets
have a lot of capacity, deep neural nets,
perhaps even more capacity.
So they, for any training set,
it's actually able to reach a
very low training error, uh,
because of that high capacity.
And so we might be in a situation where
the variance is too high. Uh, and, uh,
even though we have low bias and thus
we were not great at generalization and
thus were overfitting.
So these two problems are
actually quite different,
but depending on the situation,
the intuition is that there's one
that dominates over the other. Um,
so if we are under fitting and there
are ways we can try to measure this,
if the training error is very
close to the validation set there,
then perhaps we'll under fitting then one
solution is to use better optimization
methods than just to
cast a great in dissent.
And this isn't current active area of
research as in the right now in 2013.
Uh,
and I'm not going to talk too much about
this because I don't want to talk too
much about optimization in this class,
but there are references on the
website of the, uh, of discourse.
And we've got to talk more about the
second hypothesis, uh, over fitting,
which in my experience tends to,
uh,
be more prevalent in problems where say
we're doing, we're doing classification,
for instance,
which is the main topic of this class.
And now the approach is essentially
going to be to use better reclamation
methods, uh, for deep neural networks.
And we'll look at two types of
virtualization approaches. One,
which is based on the corporation of
unsupervised learning and the training
procedure. And another one, which is
based on the use of so-called dropout, uh,
training, which is also can be, uh,
which we can understand as a way of
improving regularization in deep neural
networks.